patty told me she said rach i already
got the script written
for the third film so if it was possible
for trevor to be worked into a third
wonder woman film
would you be in rachel this is about
wonder woman 1984.
people should go out and see this film
and if there's a third which i'm sure
there will be and if they wanted me to
come back
after people watched the second i'd be
happy to come back
with bells on and uh wearing a tutu you
know
all right i feel like wonder woman 1984
is exactly what the world needs right
now this on-screen chemistry
that deep deep love between steve and
diana
what did it feel like to be thrust into
this vibrant new decade
for the sequel of wonder woman i have a
great job my job is
to go to work with patty and gal and to
fall in love with diana prince over and
over again
and support wonder woman on her
incredible journey
this is a story about a woman a force of
nature whose greatest
weapon is love and compassion and
forgiveness and kindness
we're finishing a pretty awful year for
humankind
so to finish off 2020 to be reminded
that
there is hope and there is beauty in
this world
and that this woman reminds us to always
see the best in people
even even when they seem and can do
very awful things and i think it's a
great reminder
it absolutely is and we love that theme
of love and compassion but i also love
the theme
of 80s fashion because honey we are set
in 1984 in this film and i talked to gal
and she was like
the one thing i would love to leave back
behind in the 80s
is the fanny pack you know what i'm
ready to go
i think we can do better parachute pants
yeah does everybody parachute now so
my burning question for you chris is
where do you stand on the fanny pack is
it something that needs to be left
behind
or do you feel like it needs to be
rocked proudly and boldly i don't think
there's any need to bring it back
i think it's i think it's doing just
fine i mean i
i went i i walk my dog
all the time and the first thing i pick
up is my fanny pack i got treats
for the dog i got the poop bags i got a
water bowl
i got a ball for i got
uh my flip phone i got my chapstick i
got
an extra you know pair of shades in case
i need it pair of flip-flops too
more inflatable mattress in case i get
locked out of the house and i gotta have
like
somewhere you know like aaa card
there's a layer yeah flashlight
yeah flashlight yeah
there's a lot of great things for the
fanny pack honey that's why it needs to
come back
and stay i guess you know from the work
from chris pond's mouth y'all it is a
fashionable statement
now i also love the scene where you are
tossing
well you and diana are tossing fashion
advice she's giving you some fashion
advice
in real life where do you stand with
that do you like to give
and receive some fashion advice with
your significant other do you like to
say oh
darling this would look good on you or
thanks you like this on me
yeah god absolutely come on i'm a virgo
so i have i tend to be very
i can be very particular i think my
girlfriend thinks i dress like an
insane person most of the time uh
but yeah no we uh i definitely
we get a good kick out of giving each
other advice that neither one of us will
listen to anyway so oh my gosh i mean
it's probably the fanny pack chris just
saying especially if you've got all that
stuff in it
yeah especially if i'm wearing three at
one time which then essentially becomes
a fanny belt
[Laughter]
i love it i love it you mentioned gal
and patty and those two women
are just special that's all i can say
they're incredible women
what is it like for you to team up be on
a set with these two boss ladies they
picked up a producer credit for
this sequel what is that ambiance like
on set with them
yeah you know i i'm uh
i'm so used to it i guess maybe growing
up in a family with strong women or
um uh it's so
uh yeah i don't know it's so normal
they're incredible women
um uh what i love about both of them is
that what you see is what you get
you know that you you interview them and
they are
those people patty is strong and dynamic
and forceful
and opinionated and direct and
you know she personifies on set what i
think is the greatest aspects of any
great director which is you know you
have to be both general patton
and you know carl jung you have to be
like the most
incredibly adept psychologist and all so
you have to run a team of hundreds of
people
on a 250 million dollar corporate
account
um and gal is just she is
i mean when i say that like the woman
has put through paces on set what would
like what she's got to wear and do and
what she's wearing and
she's got a family of you know two young
girls she's traveling with them
and she's producing and she's got it etc
etc
and she's never she never complains she
i don't see her ever not
smile i don't see her ever not laugh i
mean i just think i would be the biggest
pain in the ass
and she is she's a delight she's an
absolute delight and that just resonates
i mean not only
on screen with you guys but like also in
our interviews uh
you guys are a delightful bunch to say
the least and patty told me she said
rach i already got the script written
for the third film
so if it was possible for trevor to be
worked into
a third wonder woman film would you be
in
rachel this is about wonder woman 1984.
people should go out and see this film
run it at home enjoy the ever living
daylights out of it watch the times buy
it a bunch of times
make some popcorn get some milk duds get
your pod
this is grandma's chicken soup for 2020.
we've had a
bad year this movie is all sorts of
awesome fun
it's got great romance it's funnier than
hell
kristen with pedro pascal and if there's
a third which i'm sure there will be and
if they wanted me to come back
after people watched the second i'd be
happy to come back
with bells on and uh wearing a tutu you
know that's what we love here it's ding
bring your fanny pack in your tin too
baby yeah okay in the meantime we don't
want to brush things yes we have
uh this one wonder woman 1984 to look
forward to
but you are already back at work with
don't worry darling it is
olivia wilde's anticipated directorial
project buzzy names are a part of this
film including your own
what is it like being a part of this
project with
these great names i mean it's incred i
finished that film actually i'm now in
london doing another film so i am a busy
dude which i'm very thankful for and
very grateful for
um shooting that was wonderful olivia
again is very clear about what she wants
the aesthetic of the movie is beautiful
the story is so compelling and
so fun and so dark and twisted florence
is an incredible actress
i can't speak more highly ever this is
the second time i've worked with her and
um every time i work with her i say i
have to meet your parents
because however they raised you they
should be teaching seminars
harry styles is an absolute delight he's
the
one of the most professional people i've
ever met couldn't be kinder
more gracious um uh
i mean really i was like i was stunned
by this this kid he's
just off the charts cool um it's just a
great cast a great group again you know
life is short so hopefully you get a
chance to
make good art with people you really
enjoy and
and i've been really really lucky in
that regard
[Music]